ينتقل الى
المعتز بالله حسن مراسل الجزيره من مدينه
اضنه يعني ايضا المشهد مشابه لباقي
المناطق والمدن المنكوبه خلفك عشرات من
عمال الانقاذ والمتطوعين يحاولون انقاذ من
يمكن انقاذه من تحت الانقاذ قرب لنا صوره
اكثر المعتز
[موسيقى]
اليها نحن امام معضلتين اساسيتين الاولى
هي سباق الزمن من اجل الوصول الى ناجين في
حال كان وجود في حال كان هناك ناجون قبل
قليل لا ينقطع الامل طبعا حسن قبل قليل
قبل ساعه تقريبا من الان خرج سبعين
بسياره اسعاف من هذا المكان ما يعني انه
ما يعني ان الامل ما زال موجودا لكن ايضا
هناك قتلى يخرجون من هذا المكان وبالتالي
هذه هي المعضله الاولى معضله سباق الزمن
للوصول الى ناجين في هذه الانقاذ الكبيره
في المكان طبعا انا اتحدث عن اضنه ولكن
هذه الصوره هي نفسها في كثير من المدن
التي تعرضت للزلزال المعضله الثانيه هي
معضله ايواء الناس الذين تشردوا من بيوتهم
جراء الزلزال اليوم هذه المدينه هي عباره
عن ابنيه عاليه هذه الابنيه تصدع كثير
منها وبالتالي لم يعد الناس العوده لهذه
الابنيه وبالتالي هم الان في الهواء الطلق
او في الخيم والشوادر التي تضعها السلطات
لايوائهم اليوم المرحله هي مرحله الانقاذ
ولكن مرحله البناء والتعمير هذه ستاخذ
فتره وهذا يعني ان القضيه لن تنتهي فقط
بالوصول الى ناجينا او القتلى او ازاله
الانقاذ هذه لحظه يطلق فيها هذه اللحظه
حسن ان يصمت الجميع لمحاوله الاستماع الى
ما اذا كان هناك صوت ياتي من الانقاض نحن
نتابع معكم هذه الصور عبر شاشه الجزيره
لمحاوله الانقاذ في مدينه اضنه وهذه
النقطه هي واحده من نقاط عده في المدينه
ويشبه الوضع هنا الان يعود العمال للعمل
تشبه الوضع هنا الوضع في جميع المناطق
التي تعرضت للزلزال حسن هذه الصوره هي في
مناطق الجنوبيه تركيا ونفس الصوره ربما هي
ايضا في شمال سوريا ان لم يكن الامر اصعب
هنا يوجد اليات يوجد متطوعين كثر هناك
ربما الوضع قد يكون اصعب ايضا